[Música]
regresamos con ustedes en Francia 24 Mi
nombre es Ángela Gómez para el análisis
de lo que ha sido una noticia histórica
hoy en el mundo el fallecimiento de la
Reina Isabel II y el cambio en la
sucesión al Trono con su hijo Carlos que
en adelante será conocido como El Rey
Carlos tercero vamos ahora a hacer un
repaso en la historia y para ello está
en el estudio de frases 24 mi compañero
Álvaro Cordero Álvaro Gracias Muchas
gracias Ángela buenas tardes Bueno lo
pusieron a correr para prepararnos este
informe y vamos a empezar por la
pregunta que ha sido la que hemos
repetido durante todo el día Cuál es la
importancia histórica de la reina
Isabeles para el Reino Unido pues es
prácticamente absoluta Ángela De hecho
no solamente es la reina más longeva en
la historia de la humanidad sino que
además fue la encargada de liderar al
Reino Unido como jefa de estado en un
periodo de decadencia que para aquel
entonces era muy era muy grave para el
Reino Unido no tengamos en cuenta que
Reino Unido era un imperio colonial y
que en el año 1952 es cuando empieza el
proceso de descolonización en otros
continentes como África Asia u Oceanía
no entonces la Reina Isabel II tuvo que
hacer frente en este proceso para Reino
Unido Y la verdad es que lo consiguió
hacer de una forma bastante correcta
bastante bien porque consiguió formar un
organismo tan importante para Reino
Unido actualmente y durante las últimas
las últimas décadas como es la common
Wells un organismo que destaca por esa
conexión que os sigue manteniendo Reino
Unido con sus antiguas colonias con
respecto en comparación por ejemplo con
con lo que lo que sucedió en Francia o
en España que esa conexión no existió no
hubo una serie de guerras independencias
y demás y ese fue el gran éxito que
logró Isabel segunda durante durante su
reinado el intentar mantener la cohesión
de Reino Unido en un proceso de
decadencia que desde luego no fue fácil
para este país hemos dado algunas
pinceladas de cómo fue su llegada al
Trono Pero bueno para eso está usted
aquí para contarnos cómo que llegó al
Trono esta monarca Pues bueno Isabel II
no estaba destinada a ser reina de Reino
Unido sino que la persona que estaba
destinada a ocupar este cargo era su tío
Eduardo VIII pero Eduardo VIII se vio
envuelto una serie de polémicas en la
década de 1930 relacionado con su
matrimonio con con su con su esposa ya
que está esta señora era una era una
señora que era venía de un divorcio
anterior y bueno Esto causaba muchísima
polémica en el Reino Unido de la época
un país recordemos muy tradicional para
aquellos años e hizo que finalmente
Eduardo VIII tuviese que abdicar en el
año 1936
esto que conllevó que su hermano Jorge
vi el actual el padre de Isabel II
asumiera este rol de rey y eso convirtió
Isabel II en la heredera al Trono para
para suceder a su padre años después la
de Jorge vi al Trono de Reino Unido
llegó en un momento muy delicado previo
a la Guerra Mundial e hizo que Jorge vi
posteriormente liderase Reino Unido en
este conflicto mundial contra la
Alemania nazi ya a partir de estos años
se empezó a vislumbrar el carácter de
Isabel II al carácter que siempre marcó
a esta a esta a esta monarca cuando
empezó a colaborar en una serie de
ayudas como enfermera en la Segunda
Guerra en la Segunda Guerra Mundial
es a partir de este momento cuando
progresivamente Isabel segunda que como
ahí te había comentado no recibió una
una educación adecuada o la educación
típica que se suele recibir Los Monarcas
es cuando en este momento hizo el
segundo empezó a salir cada vez más a
tener un rol cada vez más protagónico
como como heredera al Trono y su momento
llegó cuando apenas tenía 25 años en el
año 1952 es aquí cuando su padre de
forma prematura falleció a un cáncer de
pulmón y ella asumió este este este
cargo con apenas 25 años como te
comentaba y una experiencia Bueno pues
todavía limitada en estos primeros años
jugó un papel muy importante el ex
Primer Ministro Winston Churchill y
bueno es a partir de aquí cuando ya
empezamos a ver a la que luego sería la
reconocidísima figura de Isabel II
Cuáles fueron los desafíos iniciales de
esta larguísima monarquía de Reina
Isabel segunda pues como te comentaba
los desafíos iniciales que tuvo Isabel
II sobre todo tienen que ver con el
contexto internacional en el año 1952
estábamos en plena guerra fría entre dos
grandes potencias la unión soviética y
Estados Unidos y Reino Unido tenía un
papel de gran Imperio en decadencia
entonces básicamente Reino Unido tenía
que encontrar su lugar en el mundo y en
especial en el bloque occidental el que
estaba liderado ahora por Estados Unidos
y no por ellos Entonces estos desafíos
eran muy importantes para para una
monarca tan joven que había asumido el
trono con apenas 25 años y bueno en un
principio todo parecía indicar que
podría ser un aspecto negativo o que
pudiese llevar a la duda Pero Isabel II
consiguió mantener
la firmeza en este aspecto y lo primero
que hizo por ejemplo nada más asumir el
cargo como reina fue
viajar a todas las antiguas a todas las
colonias en ese momento de Reino Unido
para intentar consolidar lo que luego
sería la commonwealth y además hablemos
de la importancia que tenía para el
Reino Unido la creación de una
organización precisamente
pues era vital si quería conservar
cierta influencia sobre todos estos
países que estaban destinados a ser
independientes como te comentaba otras
otras grandes potencias como Francia o
España tuvieron procesos de
descolonización muy traumáticos con
largas guerras con altos costos
económicos altos costos humanos y bueno
Reino Unido supo supo manejar esa
situación de una forma algo diferente
aunque sí como conflictos Como por
ejemplo en la India pero consiguió que
varias de estas naciones de hecho 54 se
mantuvieron Dentro de este paraguas de
la commonwealth que unía de forma
económica y en algunos casos política a
estas antiguas colonias con Reino Unido
no hay más que ver que por ejemplo en la
actualidad
14 estados Son son todavía pertenecen a
son Isabel segunda Perdón es la jefa de
estado de 14 naciones entre ellas
Australia Canadá o Nueva Zelanda
Entonces esta importancia del de su
figura en el aspecto político siguió
existiendo después de después de todo
una figura que ahora tiene que cambiar
como las monedas como el himno nacional
y como muchos símbolos en el Reino Unido
con la Asunción de Carlos pero los
desafíos externos Álvaro no fueron lo
único a lo que tuvo que hacer frente de
la Reina Isabel II hablemos un poco de
esas crisis internas que tuvo que
afrontar Durante los siguientes años la
crisis interna más importante que se
vivió durante su reinado quizá fue el
conflicto en Irlanda del Norte este
enfrentamiento entre Los partidarios de
permanecer en Reino Unido y los
defensores de reunificar Irlanda dejó
cientos de muertos en esta nación y de
hecho afectó de lleno a la convivencia
diaria de Reino Unido la reina vio
durante estos años
los atentados terroristas se convertían
en una tónica habitual en algunas
regiones incluido en el mismo Londres y
este conflicto solamente se vería su
final en el año 1998 con la llegada de
los acuerdos del viernes Santo entre las
dos partes que estaban enfrentadas
y en total fueron 15 primeros ministros
o los que pasaron por su oficina para
empezar su gobierno que fueron
designados Bajo su reinado cual de todos
ellos usted destacaría más Álvaro creo
que es más importante de todos los de
los 15 primeros ministros que han pasado
por su reinado sería margaret thatcher
no solamente porque estuvo 11 años en
ese cargo sino por todas las cosas que
sucedieron durante esos 11 años hay que
recordar que durante el periodo de
Tacher Reino Unido vivió una guerra
contra Argentina por las malvinas que
desde luego hizo que este país volviera
a tener una gran un gran despliegue
militar para defender lo consideraban
que eran unos territorios suyos y que
Bajo su punto de vista O al menos el de
la ex primera ministra margaret thatcher
era un desafío a la unidad de Reino
Unido cuentan además que su relación
entre entre Isabel II y margaret
thatcher no era la más a la más idónea
de hecho dicen que Isabel II en varias
ocasiones
contra estuvo en contra de algunos de
las decisiones de margaret thatcher y su
esto hizo que su relación se tensara en
más de una ocasión es por ejemplo
conocido que Isabel II estaba en contra
del aparates en Sudáfrica y que margaret
thatcher por el contrario sí que
defendía este tipo de políticas y esta
posturas hicieron que en algunas
ocasiones las dos
líderes políticas se encontraron Aunque
eso sí siempre se mantuvieron un gran
respeto entre las dos las noticias de la
monarquía Siempre han estado en los
titulares pero curiosamente Álvaro no se
trata de momentos complicados o por
cuestiones políticas sino por familiares
cuáles fueron estos momentos en una
familia que siempre ha estado bajo el
ojo público y de la cual él siempre se
esperaron altísimos estándares estos
momentos sobre todo empezaron a llegar a
partir de la década de 1980 en este
momento en el año 1980 precisamente su
hijo Carlos El Heredero al Trono se casa
con la princesa Diana y la princesa
Diana es una figura que empieza a tomar
cada vez más relevancia dentro de la
escena mediática de Reino Unido algo que
desde luego no pasa desapercibido para
la familia real la princesa Diana
mantuvo una postura poco ortodoxa para
lo que se suele estar uno acostumbrado a
lo que a la a lo que mantiene la familia
real británica con acercamientos a la
población con determinadas luchas y
reivindicaciones personales y demás y
ese tipo de posturas pues no sentaban
especialmente bien a una reina que se
caracterizó precisamente por mantener su
ortodoxia y la tradición de la familia
real en el cargo no estas tensiones
además fueron aumentadas por otras
cuestiones como los adulterios tanto
cometidos por Carlos su hijo como por
Diana diferentes escándalos que ocuparon
las portadas del Reino Unido durante
semanas e incluso años y Bueno pues todo
esto llevó a una a una a una creación de
un ambiente un poco extraño dentro de la
familia real que todavía se empeora más
cuando en el año 1992 Bueno pues se
anunció la separación de este matrimonio
de Carlos y Diana junto además con la
separación del matrimonio de otros dos
hijos de la reina el año 1992 es el Que
conoció la Reina Isabel II en un
discurso pronunciado por ella misma como
el anus horribilis el año horrible para
ella no porque a todos estos divorcios
se sumó el incendio en el castillo de
Windsor uno de los castillos más
importantes para la familia real
británica y que desde luego hicieron que
Isabel II que no se caracterizaba por
dar unos discursos especialmente
opinativos se atreviera a decir que haya
sido su peor año como reina hasta hasta
ese momento y quedémonos un rato más
hablando de Lady di porque 25 años
después de su fallecimiento sigue siendo
una de las figuras más icónicas en la
historia de los Windsor y de esta
monarquía Pero además implicó un momento
delicado para la imagen de la monarquía
en sí misma y de la Reina Isabel segunda
una de tantas tormentas que tuvo que
afrontar y un cambio de paradigma desde
luego fue la tormenta más complicada que
tuvo que afrontar Isabel II cuando su
popularidad que normalmente siempre fue
muy alta se vio en el punto más bajo
Lady falleció hace 25 años como
comentabas Ángela el 31 de agosto de
1997 y su fallecimiento supuso un shock
para todo Reino Unido y para gran parte
del mundo porque era como te comentaba
era una figura muy muy icónica y
mediática a nivel global Qué sucedió
este fallecimiento llevó a que millones
de personas se lamentaran y lloraran la
pérdida de pero la Reina Isabel II junto
con toda la familia real no se
pronunciaron Durante los primeros días
se recluyeron en el castillo de balmoral
en el Palacio de balmoral en Escocia y
no hicieron ningún tipo de comunicado
durante las primeras horas algo que
causó muchísima controversia dentro del
Reino Unido y en general en todo el
mundo porque no se entendía Por qué
Isabel segunda no hablaba sobre la que
había sido su nuera y con una figura tan
importante como era Lady di esta
cuestión está controversia hizo que
finalmente Isabel II tuviera que dar Un
paso atrás y tuviera que al final viajar
hasta Londres presentarse en el funeral
de Lady di y al final ofrecer un funeral
de con honores de estado prácticamente a
la princesa Diana y un discurso en el
que valoraba como era esta persona algo
que al finalizó que remontara otra vez
su popularidad y que luego mejorará
Durante los siguientes años pero en un
principio su popularidad se vio muy
cantidad después del fallecimiento de
Diana bueno Y es que esta tradicional
actuación de la monarquía en la que no
hay pronunciamientos y no se toma
partido Pues fue una característica muy
visible de la reina de Isabel II que
siempre se tomó su tiempo para hacer
apariciones públicas o para hacer
declaraciones en público a una mujer que
además era conocida por su timidez y por
tener que afrontarla Pues a lo largo de
70 años de reinado y pues esta noticia
de Lady di no fue la decepción y bueno
se la cobró la historia en su momento
pero ahora hablemos ya para ir hacia el
cierre Álvaro de lo que trajo la llegada
del Siglo 21 a la monarca la llegada del
Siglo 21 supuso una una consolidación de
su figura como monarca de su figura como
jefa de estado y de su figura como reina
Pero aún así Isabel II tuvo que afrontar
varios desafíos tanto políticos como
personales durante estos años cabe
recordar que en el año 2002 por ejemplo
falleció su hermana Margarita y fa
también la reina madre su madre que
durante todo ese tiempo la había estado
acompañado en su travesía como como
monarca además de ello una serie de
cuestiones políticas en la que destaca
especialmente el brexit marcó a la Reina
Isabel II después de haber liderado como
jefa de estado toda la creación de la
Unión Europea y el proceso de entrada de
Reino Unido en la Unión Europea
finalmente Tuvo Tuvo que ver durante sus
últimos años como su nación salía de
esta organización para afrontar la
cuestión internacional de una forma
Autónoma lejos de los dictámenes de
Bruselas además de todo esto lo más
reciente que ha tenido que enfrentar en
el plano familiar es el fallecimiento de
su esposo El príncipe de edimburgo El
príncipe Felipe de edimburgo que como
todos decían Era uno de los Pilares
fundamentales de la Reina Isabel II a la
hora de reinar en Reino Unido y que su
fallecimiento Obviamente le su una gran
pérdida para ella y un problema difícil
de afrontar que además se sumaban a
otros como la cuestión de su nieto el
príncipe Harry y de su esposa Meghan
markle que siempre mantuvo una serie de
polémicas y bueno que es al final se
alojaron de la familia real Aunque bueno
esto ya fueron prácticamente los últimos
compases de su reinado hasta hasta hoy
hasta la actualidad
un poco más de un año en aproximadamente
abril del año pasado estábamos dando la
noticia del fallecimiento del Duque de
edimburgo y que también vino con
recaídas en el estado de salud para
Isabel segunda y bueno Hemos llegado así
hasta este momento de la historia Álvaro
a usted el agradecimiento por este
repaso Muchas gracias